[Music]
we've had hand to hand fights and gun
fights
so how about sword fights for a change
swords are cool
that's why that and i think the sword
fights create a unique opportunity for
choreography that the other types of
battles don't and what better item to
represent anime than good old swords of
all variants let's not waste any more
time and get slashing with the 10 most
impactful sword fights in anime let's
begin with yato vs ravo
noragami is such an underrated gem it
was one of my favorites in the season
when it was airing
and i feel a bit sad that it's generally
been forgotten these days i've loved
action shows that dealt with the
supernatural since forever but i think
that noragami has a certain moral and
philosophical edge that gives people
another
incentive to watch it the first season
of the show ends with an anime original
filler that actually gave us one of the
best fights of the season
despite yato only knowing one real move
norigami excels in the showcasing of
powers and unique applications of
weapons
and this fight is one of the prime
examples of that at the end it is
ultimately a fight with more focus on
the character drama
instead of the actual fighting and
created one of the most touching scenes
in the first season
second only to eugene's absolution once
the drama has been dealt with
yato just finishes off his opponent
quickly to end an origami version of
rurouni kenshin's first army
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
that one nice show that gave us some
nice and flashy fights
unfortunately it doesn't seem that a lot
of people have seen it so perhaps this
fight can convince you to give it a try
we have what seemed to be a simple fight
between alfonso and leon
two characters who end up shaping the
narrative in major ways going forward
however everything starts off small
and before they fight in the climax they
get some one-on-one time
in terms of stakes and the sheer power
being displayed i won't say this fight
is the best among those in garo
however in terms of animation and
ambiance i don't think that even the
climactic fight comes close i just want
to give a shout out to the guy who
directed and designed this sword fight
such an underrated gem in an underrated
anime it would also help to set the tone
for the eventual confrontation near the
finale
jin and mugen vs karia makes it to the
list as its number 8 entry
i didn't expect hip-hop and samurai to
make an amazing combination but what
we've got here
was one of the most unique shows out
there in terms of swag and flare the
show actually has a lot of cool fights
but i think that the battle against
karya is the best one among them
samurai champloo fights are really
oozing with character
and such can be seen in this conflict
you have three very badass swordsmen and
you can really tell how unique their
fighting styles are just by watching
this fight
you don't even need context and you can
just tell what these characters are like
by skimming through the battle
it's just so fluid and smooth perfect
for what samurai shampoo prides itself
on
the crispness of the fight has aged so
well and i think this kind of animation
is one of the key reasons the more
veteran anime fans still remember
samurai champloo so fondly to this day
let's proceed with guns blazing and well
i mean sword swinging with one of my
favorite battles in kill la kill
killakil has no shortage of cool and
epic fights and i think that this last
battle between ryuko and satsuki is just
the perfect way to cap off the first
part of the series
it's a flashy finale meant to satisfy
everyone
just in time before what we know of the
series gets turned upside down
pretty much what makes kia luckil so
amazing can be seen in this fight
over-the-top action top-tier voice
acting
and the sheer big fight feel i can't
find a fight that culminates an arc as
well as this within the series well
there's the goosebumps inducing finale
where marco had her time to shine
but that's not really a sword fight if i
include the whole thing it's too bad
that a lot of people back in the day
shan kill luckily for the perceived
sexuality they missed out on such a
great fight and a very rich plot that
non-anime fans wouldn't expect
[Music]
when one thinks of naruto one doesn't
really expect a lot out of sword fights
people expect the crazy powers
the super enhanced hand-to-hand combat
and other stuff that technically don't
qualify as ninjutsu honestly speaking
however in between the wild powers we do
get some good old sword fights here and
there and one of the best ones in my
opinion is the one where killer bee
and sasuke face off it may just be me
but killer b represents sasuke's first
real test that's not his brother
ever since he got his own faction a
battle between the eight tails and
sasuke's eye powers would have given
people expectations
what i didn't expect back then was a
cool sword fight
it's also surreal to see sasuke and
friends just get wrecked in this fight
the plot armor seems to have been
removed for sasuke and the whole group
simply get their asses handed to them of
course shenanigans have to come in to
extend the fight and push it to the next
phase but it's no doubt that this fight
really helped push
kiloby and made him look like a far more
impressive fighter than people thought
whether with his magical powers or with
the sword
[Music]
is the conclusion that doraro watchers
have been waiting for and it didn't
disappoint in the slightest
i really like the take they did on dora
when they modernized it they modified
some traits with the characters
and all that made this final battle a
lot more exciting and immersive for me
it's been a long time coming
fukiyakimaru and his quest to make his
body whole again
and the ending of his journey leads him
to a final confrontation with his own
brother
the stakes just seem a lot higher and
it's poetic for the battle to end the
way it did yakimaru has come a long way
and that's not even getting to the fight
itself which showcases the visual
wonders of modern anime if there's
anything you have to watch dora road to
the end for
it's this amazing payoff of a battle is
yakima the most badass team a slayer
there is
i'll let you decide on that one
heaven's feel is just a treat for the
eyes with all the fake media out there
saber and berserker had their fair share
of skirmishes with one another among all
of them
i think my favorite one is the heavens
feel version you wouldn't expect someone
as
big and birdie as berserker to be this
agile but he was able to match saber
blow for blow
while simply showing his combat prowess
one that ends up being more than what
saber can handle this berserker is just
a lot more cunning and skillful than
what anyone would expect it's
truly an impactful fight in both story
and meta sense in universe it represents
ilya's official entry as a formidable
master
as for us the viewers it's also not
every day that you can see animation as
flashy
and breathtaking as this seeing the
movie at the cinema was a real treat too
and i think this fight really helped set
the tone for the rest of the movie
which is great because the heavens feel
movies are just a wild ride the rest of
the way
one of the most influential anime
featuring swords rurouni kenshin ought
to make it here and what better fight to
represent it than the culmination of the
most fondly remembered ark in the entire
anime
more than just a sword fight this fight
is the climax of their battle of
ideologies
kenshin takes on the ruthless monster
that on paper would straight up overcome
him and his policy of not fighting to
kill it was a battle of conviction the
stakes have never been higher in the
series
and i don't think that anything comes
close to this fight in terms of
intensity that's not to say that the
sword swinging isn't good
the background and the context are what
i drew focus on but the fight itself is
still exciting
and is full of twists and turns often in
the form of run-ins
gin toki vs takasugi is the climactic
battle that every gintama fan dreamed of
and boy did it deliver i think that is
just the best way to finish off the long
rivalry between gentoki and dakasugi
people know gintama for the comedy and
the slapstick but when it decides to go
serious and cap off some of its
excellently written storylines you have
a payoff like this
an exhilarating fight that lets both
combatants personality shine through
no wonder gintama's a lot of people's
favorite shonen
or so it seems i mean i don't see a lot
of hate for it compared to a lot of
other popular mainstream shonen no
magical powers
power of friendship or any contrived
anime skills
just pure intensity and violence the two
bitter rivals just let their fists and
swords do the talking it's one of the
most emotional fights in the whole shown
in anime and i think that if you're
looking for just
good old swordsmanship overflowing with
a dose of energy and amazing writing
this is the one to look out for
[Music]
[Music]
uh
nanashi versus luolang makes it to the
first place on today's list
i think that it's fitting to have this
fight on this list yeah i know i've
talked about this fight a few times now
but even through a decade and a half
this fight is still one of the best
sword battles out there
it's aged beautifully and much of that
has to do with the production values and
passion that you can see from the
animators
it's yet another captivating fight
brimming with emotion and enhanced by
the beautiful visuals and sound
production
the ambiance is perfect and that's to be
expected from a theatrical production of
this scale would it be fair for me to
say that this is one of the most
impactful sword fights because it just
raised the bar for the rest of them
i think it definitely is
with that we finish this list yeah i
know there are a lot of other fights
involving swords that i didn't include
well there was only room for 10 and i
think that we should look out for those
other fights on a future list while
we're at it maybe you can suggest some
fights that you'd like to see in the
next volume
because i think it's just a matter of
when at this point before you leave
don't forget to like
subscribe and hit that sweet bell button
if you really enjoyed this content
don't forget to share the channel with
your friends and subscribe to the other
channel that i'll be linking above
that's it for now i'll see you next time
and have a good week ahead
[Music]
you